da silva frente a sus seguidores de sao
paulo en este primer sábado de campaña
oficial para el sillón presidencial de
brasil el ex presidente y candidato
izquierdista lidera la carrera según la
última encuesta de datafolha con un 47
por ciento de los sufragios frente al 32
del actual mandatario y candidato a la
reelección jair bolsonaro pero el
titular ultraderechista busca acercarse
a los sectores afines de lula como lo
muestra su nuevo programa de asistencia
social enfocado a los más necesitados
sportback de pueblo aquí es muy sabio
este pueblo sabe que quiere este pueblo
lo conoce a usted y me conoce este
pueblo sabe que a usted no le gustan los
pobres este pueblo sabe que en campania
hay gente desesperada para hablar con el
pueblo
la compañía electoral de los comicios
más polarizados en décadas arrancó el
pasado martes promete ser una batalla
entre estos dos candidatos favoritos ya
que los demás aspirantes se encuentran
muy rezagados un enfrentamiento entre
dos modelos para brasil las propuestas
socialistas de lula por un lado y por el
otro el populismo de derecha de bolt
sonaron
nuestro país no quiere dar pasos atrás
no queremos ideología de género en las
escuelas nuestro país no quiere
legalizar las drogas nuestro país
respeta la vida desde su concepción
nuestro país no quiere convertirse en un
aliado del comunismo en otros países el
2 de octubre la decisión está en manos
de los más de 156 millones de electores
de confirmarse las estimaciones el poco
margen entre ambos candidatos llevaría a
los brasileños a una segunda vuelta